but first up she's a two-time Pulitzer
Prize winner whose latest book is
leadership in turbulent times America's
historian in chief Doris Kearns Goodwin
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for coming on it's great to
see you I won't burden you with all the
Supreme Court talk on this show tonight
but I just want to ask because we often
hear from historians that oh we've seen
this before with Congress people have
acted lousy and presidents the Supreme
Court I feel was always kind of on a
pedestal is this a low or were they
acting like idiots before I don't know I
think it is a low in my lifetime which
is not short I mean the partisanship
that we saw two alternate realities
during the Cavanaugh hearings one and
the other that had nothing to do with
each other but I can go back as an
historian because I've lived with guys
in the past there were lower moments and
just imagine this in the 1850s there was
a congressman from South Carolina and he
came into the Senate floor and he hit
the Massachusetts Senator Charles Sumner
over the head with a cane falls into
unconsciousness but the most important
thing is in the South he's made a hero
just as Cavanaugh has been made a hero
now they all had canes they gave him a
golden cane but in the north here's the
positive thing it mobilized the
anti-slavery sentiment in the north they
got stronger the Republican Party the
party of Lincoln then produces Abraham
Lincoln so if we can awaken from this
new low and the citizens can get active
again we can make something from this
moment I believe it
[Music]
there's no choice there's no choice but
to be optimistic what's another thing to
just wallow in it we can't know we can't
wallow we cameo fine
you'll get toilet paper stuck in here on
HBO even let it fly okay well you know
it when you said he was a hero in the
south or reminded me of the guy who
heckled Obama and said you lie and then
he was a hero in the south maybe the
south is the problem well maybe we
should have let them go oh no no no I
played the south older when you're in
the cities it's just like anywhere else
it's really it's not a state thing it's
a city versus country thing isn't it
well you know that's what happened at
the turn of the 20th century you had a
very similar situation to now the cities
were growing the people in the rural
East felt cut off from the right had a
lot of new inventions the pace of life
was speeding up the Gilded Age gap
between the rich and the poor
but luckily then a leader came along
there was a lot of populist spirit a lot
of anti elitism and Teddy Roosevelt came
along and he was able to channel all
that emotion into something he called
the square deal between the rich and the
poor
I mean he was like Trump he came in from
a privileged background but he learned
empathy through politics he learned to
go to slums and see what it was like for
these other people to live so he's not
like drunk no he's certainly no empathy
is the most important characteristic in
a leader and it's it's what's missing in
the current president well I mean it's
not of a whole menu
you know historians and you are
certainly preeminent among them I would
consider you premise into parries of all
three misinterprets but I'd love to be
that you are thank you first among
equals for you non-latin speakers like
Zeus was preeminent okay so all right
Zeus
so is the question but you all seem to
say I guess you're all optimist that you
know oh we've seen worse before have we
did we ever have a traitor president
because I really do think we have a
traitor as a president someone who
plainly and out in the out and open
sides with them not us attacks our
Justice Department our FBI or CIA says
he agrees with Putin I could go on with
the list of things that I consider
traitorous somehow his agenda and
Putin's are exactly the same all the
time
coincidence possibly did we ever have
that I'll tell you I don't know that we
need to go to that direction right now
the molar investigation will show us
whatever is going to come forth on that
right now we just have to understand
that we have a president with no
capacity more important than if you know
what's more important is that we have to
persuade other people of why we have to
go against mr. Trump right now because
he's a traitor
no because using that language is not
going to reach the people that you want
to read but what language would you yeah
here's what I'd use I'd use the fact
that this man has no humility which is
an important part of every president old
that he has no empathy that he has no
resilience that he says that the reason
he's so humble is because the president
because the Pope is very very humble
just like Donald Trump I mean you can't
think that way but you can't you can't
be a person who says that the most
important thing is never to lose that
you always have to win every president
I've studied has gone through adversity
and they came out stronger at the other
end Ernest Hemingway said everyone's
broken by life but sometimes people are
stronger in the broken places he says
he's never experienced loss and that's
why here's the very very best
temperament of anyone who's run use
those ordinary kind of things and that's
one of the persuade people they can see
that this is not a leader this is not a
man who's experienced any kind of
empathy for other people that's what you
have to do to persuade have we ever had
a leader who was such a cult leader
I feel like more than any president I've
ever seen it's a cult no matter what he
does they stay with him well you know
what's interesting I mean I think when
FDR came into the presidency people
believed in him so much
but the difference was that his word was
his God and he made his promises real
when he first got in somebody wrote him
a letter and he said my roof fell off my
dogs run away I don't have a job my wife
has mad at me but you are there and now
everything's okay but the point is that
he made everything okay he gave those
fireside chats and people felt he was
actually talking to them and he made
good on his promises that's the
important thing to keep one's word which
is what not president Trump has done
people felt so close to FDR that they
felt like he was actually in their
living room when he was on the radio
with them there's a story of a
construction worker running home one
night and his partner said were you
going he said well my president he's
coming to speak to me in my living room
I have to be there to greet him when he
comes that's the kind of president you
need who can deal with the citizens they
feel like he's their friend that is not
the same thing as being a cult president
where they just believe whatever you say
somehow but you're not giving them what
they really hoped for that has that gap
that we never have seen this before
really never seen this okay I don't
think so we've had other president would
have been pretty bad but right not to
this level of the relationship with the
citizenry I think and do you think if in
2020 he loses the election he'll leave
because Hillary Clinton now is on my
page saying no I mean I say leave I mean
we have to believe
of course he will about so many things
and then he you know of course he's not
gonna maybe they'll give him a room in
the White House somewhere and he can
move by himself
surrounded by a no now we have to
believe in the institutions of our
country oh I believe in the interest
will be carried out if he doesn't want
to leave okay
well
do not yeah you have to believe you have
to believe in the military you have to
believe in the other institutions of the
country the checks and balances will
step forward if he's voted out if the
people say he should be gone and that's
the answer we have to awaken the
citizenry right now he can no longer be
spectators you've got to believe in the
people I'm not sure we're living in that
error anymore and also the people with
the guns like him it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter who has the gun no it
matters who has the guns but you're
being much too pissed I got to do
something with you I got to make you
more up tomorrow so you don't think
it'll get violent it's possible it could
get violent oh one of the things that
Lincoln yeah they got free you around no
no no no here's the thing in fact there
was violence in the 1830s and 40s and
Lincoln gave an amazing lecture in which
he said that the rule of law was what
had to be reinstituted in people's minds
and he said that everybody should be
reading the Revolution and the
Constitution at night to their children
like you'd read the Bible to them and
then if we remember our history we will
remember the ideals of who we are and we
will not allow these did you think
Donald Trump would ever get the
nomination no I did did you think he
could win so you're a better predictor
than me nor history at our peril if we
don't look back at these other times
when a leader came look they got us
through the depression FDR did Abraham
Lincoln got us through the Civil War and
LBJ my LBJ who I worked with when I was
24 years old he had bipartisanship in
the Congress those two sides came
together Civil Rights voting rights
Medicare aid to education we've done
this before and we can do it again all
right thank you for making me
gars Kearns Goodwin everybody